climate change will affect the poorest
the most that's absolutely true but what
you have to remember is everything bad
effects poor people most so they're most
affected by infectious diseases or bad
environments the main point is there's
something slightly odd about the whole
idea of us saying you know what I see
you I really care about you I want to
help you I'm not going to drive to work
tomorrow and that will actually mean
that I won't emit CO2 which will mean in
a hundred years your descendants will be
much warmer but slightly less much warm
that just seems almost careless
five years ago Greta thundberg tweeted
climate change will wipe out all of
humanity in five years
now she's deleted it what's going on
what so Greta tunberg is doing what I
think most rational people should really
be doing she's listening to what the
media is telling us and they're telling
us climate change is not just a problem
it's not just dangerous it's actually
likely to wipe us all out and and so you
know she's scared like many many other
people uh but of course it isn't
actually a problem that's going to end
Humanity climate change is a problem not
the end of the world if it's a problem
it's something that we should fix along
with all the other problems in the world
if it's the end of the world of course
that's the only thing we should be
focused on so I understand why there's
such a focus on making us believe this
is really the end of the world there's a
new survey of the all the rich countries
in the world the OCD it's at 60 of all
people now believe that it's likely
global warming will lead to the end of
mankind that's terrifying because that's
not what the U.N climate panel is
telling us so problem yes not the end of
the world and that's what you know Greta
she she tweeted this it was it was a bad
tweet in the first place because it
didn't actually reflect what the author
said and it just it felt right I'm sure
at the time but of course you can't
actually get away with saying that and
then you know realizing five years later
we're still here
for the people who haven't been uh fully
red pilled on the X risk definition and
why climate change doesn't meet that
criteria what's the 30 000 foot view of
that
I'm a little worried I never remember
whether it's the blue or the red pill
what what is the what is the red pill is
seeing why why is why is climate change
not a genuine existential risk so
fundamentally if you see temperatures
rise or if you saw them drop for that
matter our societies will be
ill-prepared so you know uh look at uh
you live in Austin right uh and compare
that to you know sort of Boston they're
both well adapted to where they are but
if it got very much warmer or very much
colder both would be ill-adaptive that's
the main point that if you change the
temperature of the world it'll be a
problem for all humans and of course
there'll also be problem for all other
living things so there's a real problem
here but the idea that somehow a few
degrees of temperature would then
suddenly eradicate everything is just
simply way outside of what anyone the
U.N climate panel anyone else is really
telling us there is a problem here so
the cost that you know you will have to
have more air conditioning cost of
course you'll have less heating costs
most places and you know many of those
places it'll sort of weigh out each
other but some places one will outweigh
the other dramatically so it will be
local problems it will have some
problems globally there's a lot of
researchers including a guy called uh
William nordhaus he's a economic
professor at the University of Yale in
uh in New Haven I believe uh uh and he
is the only climate Economist to get The
Nobel Prize in climate economics and he
estimates that if we do nothing about
climate for the rest of the century the
impact will feel a little bit like we're
four percent less well-off than we
otherwise would be now that's a problem
remember four percent is not the end of
the world and also if you think about it
the UN estimate that by the end of the
century the average person in the world
will be about 450 percent as rich as he
or she is today so we'll be much much
richer but because of global warming
we'll be slightly less much richer so
instead of being 450 as Rich will only
be 434 percent as Rich yes that's a
problem no it's not the end of the world
why use the metric of richness why is it
that that's the uh outcome that's being
optimized for here when it comes to
climate oh look look and and this is a
common misunderstanding that somehow
economists and especially you know sort
of welfare economists only care about
money uh you know that's not what this
is about it's just a convenient way of
measuring a lot of different things so
it'll be you know uh losses of wetlands
it'll be uh that some people will die
some people won't die it'll be a lot of
other things so we do this routinely in
many different ways uh for instance when
we decide whether to put up a traffic
circle or I believe it round about in in
America uh or you know if we put up
Highway protection in the in the median
or lots of other things do we hand out
vaccines or make expensive uh operating
procedures uh operation sorry we decide
on that from a societal point of view on
saying how much more good does it do and
that will typically be in safe lives or
if we're talking about nature and
preserved nature compared to how many
resources we spend
economists tend to translate all of that
into money because it's a convenient
measure but it's just one measure uh
it's a fairly important one because that
is what very often correlates very very
well with pretty much anything else we
know that you know if you're if you have
higher incomes you also might likely to
survive more you're likely to have more
spare time you're likely to be better
educated you have lots and lots of other
attributes that are similar in the sense
of desirable oh you also have better
environment typically so the the point
here is it's just one measure and many
of getting a sense of what is the size
of this
when it comes to existential risk the
proper definition of existential risk
permanent unrecoverable collapse right
of human civilization
um it really does it's been a a pet
irritant of mine ever since I started
reading Nick Bostrom and Toby odd that
people see climate change as an actual
existential risk when I say existential
risk permanent unrecoverable collapse we
are all paper clips we're all gray goo
or we are basically permanently locked
into being in the Stone Age and we can't
get back out of it again almost all of
the things that people focus their
attention on stuff like climate change
nuclear war even nuclear war every nuke
goes off not an existential risk now
unaligned super intelligent AGI
big existential risk nanotechnology big
existential risk engineered pandemics
big existential risk
I am blown away by the fact that of all
of the Myriad of different X risks that
we could be focused on
climate change is the one that's
galvanized the most public attention and
Toby's book The precipice which is great
says it's got a one in one thousand or
no sorry one in ten thousand chance over
the next hundred years of being the end
of human civilization whereas I think
AGI is one in ten engineered pandemics
are one in ten natural pandemics are one
in 30
basically it seems like all of the
attention is focused on something which
doesn't require it or deserve it why
welcome to the media age right this is
this is fundamentally because climate
change has all the great pictures it
also has some other things that are very
desirable like for instance you get to
sell a lot of stuff uh so last year we
spent about 1.1 trillion dollars on
climate policy a lot of people are
making money off of this so obviously
they're pushing this uh when we have the
big climate meeting in Denmark uh uh in
2009 where we were going to save the
world as they always have to do in in
those meetings uh uh Vestas our big uh
uh wind turbine producer I believe still
the world's biggest uh uh wind turbine
producer they've plasted everywhere in
Copenhagen would say get a great
agreement which you know I'm sure
they're nice guys and they actually want
that but also it was a basic way of
saying and make us lots and lots of
money so so there's a lot of reasons why
uh with climate you can basically turn
every weather story Into Climate
catastrophe a potential climate
catastrophe it's great for for visuals
it's very very hard to do that with gray
goo or with artificial intelligence or
even if you think about it uh back in
2019 virtually nobody took a pandemic
seriously
we knew it was going to happen I mean we
were very lucky that coach Bill Gates
won this Bill Gates won this in what
2014 that favorite famous video and look
we saw it in 1918 right so it's not like
it it's a surprising unprecedented
and and yeah we've seen this many times
and and of course asteroids is an
obvious uh uh point we know that they
can basically kill everything in in the
universe so so I think one of the points
that I tried to do and I guess that's
also why you'd like me on on the show is
I tried as hell tell people this is not
about what looks best on TV or in this
case most scary on TV
it's about where we can actually do the
most
good for every dollar spent now there's
another thing and that's where
economists tend to get really annoying
as well as of course to say some things
we can fix fairly cheaply some things
are incredibly hard to do something
about and and so again I would tend to
say let's focus on the places where we
can make a huge impact at low cost first
before we try and that's unfortunately
what climate is we try to make a small
impact in a long time from now at an
incredibly high cost which is not very
effective
yeah so what you're trying to do is
front load some of the gains that you
can get because it's easy we have
probably the technology at the moment to
be able to do it there are some problems
that you could foresee if you project
out where technology is going that we
may be more able to do it at a better
price point in the future
so
okay you've been doing this research
you've got this new big chunk of
research that you've spent an awfully
long time doing which is looking at
the most cost effective ways to make the
world a better place
what did that involve what have you
discovered what was surprising
so back into
teen
we're all set targets for the world
they're called the sustainable
development goals you may have heard of
them uh the U.S to sign up Britain has
signed up every country in the world
that was that thing where there was a
hundred 180 of them or something 169
targets or goals uh so we basically
promised everything to everyone
everywhere all the time uh and you know
the guys who did this in New York these
were all U.N ambassadors undoubtedly
felt really cool about being able to say
I promise this oh and I also promise
this and I promise you know we basically
just promised our own promise to you
promised to you uh but but you know
that's not how the world works and so
not surprisingly we're actually failing
on pretty much all of the promises now
they're all nice promises yeah so
they're you know stop poverty stop
hunger stop climate change uh stop
corruption stop War stop you know
anything you don't like and do
everything you do like make make sure
everybody has good jobs and there's also
some really odd ones in there you know
we should recycle more and we should eat
more Organics and we should have more uh
Parks accessible for for handicapped
people and yeah
it's slightly different levels of of
attention but what we tried to do back
then was to basically tell them please
some of these goals some of these
targets some of these promises are
incredibly effective you can spend a few
dollars and do an amazing amount of good
some of them are going to be incredibly
expensive and really hard to do like you
know stop War for instance so maybe you
should start focusing on the stuff
that's really doable and effective first
and no they didn't listen I I met with a
lot of them they loved this idea and
they said you know this is all great but
the reality was you know when you meet
with Brazil's in basketball I'm not
pulling out Brazil for any good reason
right but you know he would say but
fundamentally I'm here to tell what
Brazil's five points are and meet with
Norwegian Ambassador and he wanted
Norway he's four points in there and
that's how we ended up with 169 uh
targets so we try to look across all
these different areas and say where can
you do good one of the things that
everybody talks about is climate
obviously but the problem is you can
spend trillions of dollars in literally
trillions of dollars and make no impact
today that's just how the climate system
works make a tiny change in 50 or 100
years now that's not nothing you know if
we had infinite resources we should also
do that but it's funny that people worry
so very little about the fact that many
people live terrible lives right now you
know so about half the world's
population live in low and Low Middle
income countries so less than eleven
dollars a day and these guys could use a
lot of things that in the rich world we
take for granted so you know they die
from easily curable infectious diseases
they don't have enough food they have
terrible education they're all these
problems there so what we try to
basically say is shouldn't we take a
look across all these different areas
that we're promising and say if we can't
do it all what should we do first so
that was a very very long way of saying
this is why we've been doing this so
what we've tried to do is with lots of
economists say where can you spend a
dollar or Yen or rupee or whatever your
currency is and make the biggest ban
and it turns out that some things are
incredibly effective some things are not
let me just tell you one so we found 12
great things and obviously you know uh
we we've uh set a cut off point and this
is sort of what's called benefit cost of
analysis we look at what are all the
costs not just the uh the economic cost
but also social and environmental costs
and likewise we look at what are all the
benefits so not just economic but also
social and environmental and then we try
to say we're looking for the really good
ones the one that deliver at least 15 of
good for every dollar you spend this is
not investment advice so you you can't
actually make your money back right
you're doing good with your dollar but
what we found for instance was education
so it's clearly a huge problem so around
the world we have spent the last what 50
years getting people educated getting
them out of illiteracy and that's great
we got most kids into school today but
unfortunately there's a what the
academics call a learning crisis
nobody's learning anything or very very
many don't learn anything so they can
technically read but they can't
understand a sentence so let me just
give you one example uh so we ask people
around the world not we I don't do this
a lot of really smart people do this I'm
I'm just aggregating all this stuff uh
but they ask uh you know 10 year olds to
read this sentence Vijay has a red hat a
blue shirt and yellow shoes
what color is the Hat
this is not super complicated I mean the
right answer is red uh but unfortunately
eighty percent of all kits in the
developing world in the port low and
lower middle income countries can't
answer this question so they've learned
technically to spell their way through
this these sentences but they don't they
can't string the words together and
that's a terrible outcome because that
means they committed to Poverty even if
we sort of get everything else right
they still can't be very productive and
so what we've tried to estimate is what
would it take to make schools better and
there's a lot of knowledge about what
doesn't and what does work so one of the
things is uh you want to make better
schools how do you do that well you give
teachers better pay uh a lot of people
will argue that uh they did that in for
instance Indonesia Indonesia double
teacher pay uh back in the uh around
2010 uh and uh because they did it in
different districts in different times
we can actually estimate the impact on
this on
kids learning outcomes turns out there
was no learning outcome uh the famous
paper is called double for nothing uh so
you know fundamentally we spent twice as
much money it made the teachers much
happier not surprisingly but it didn't
have any measurable impact on the
learning of kids there's a lot of other
studies that show what doesn't work but
here is the stuff that does work
the real problem in schools is that you
put all the 12 year olds together in one
group all the 13 year olds and other
group and so on but these guys are
vastly different in their outcomes some
are really smart and know a lot of stuff
and are incredibly bored and some have
no clue what's going on and everywhere
in between right what is the teacher
going to do if you have like 30 or 60
kids in your class you're sort of
teaching to some middle ground and most
kids are either incredibly bored or
totally lost
instead what you should do is teach at
the right level you should teach at
their level one way you can do that is
by giving each of these kids a tablet
we're not actually going to give them a
tablet because that's really expensive
they get to sit in front of a tablet one
hour a day and then some other kids are
going to be using for the other hours of
the day if you do that
and you have software that very quickly
realize you know they know that oh it's
Chris he's back and they'll know pretty
much your level and then they will start
teach you right from there it turns out
that that tablet one hour a day can
teach you so much that by the end of the
year you'll have learned three times as
much as what you normally would have
done you've learned three years of
school in one year of schooling and you
know the cost is about thirty dollars
per kid so that's for you need to have
solar panels to recharge the uh them you
need uh you know some lockers for the
tablets because otherwise they're going
to get stolen and all that kind of stuff
but fundamentally this is super cheap
and could do an amazing amount of good
so there are some other uh Solutions in
there we try to estimate What's the
total cost of doing this for 90 so
there's almost half a billion kids in
the low and Low Middle income countries
each year they need to get this
education that's better it's going to
cost almost 10 billion dollars but you
know what the benefit is and we again
calculate that in dollars but the real
benefit is that they will learn more
they'll go out and be productive when
they're old old enough and they will
help both build more wealth for
themselves and for their societies but
the benefit of those 10 billion dollars
is 600 billion dollars we can make the
world 600 billion dollars richer that's
60 back on each dollar how amazing is
that that's the kind of points that
we're trying to make so I'm sorry I just
you know talked for way too long but I I
think in some ways this is the central
point this is not sexy but it's
incredibly useful and those are the
kinds of things that we should be
focused on
how close do you see this work that
you're doing to the effective altruism
movement
so effective altruism I love the uh
those guys and and they're a lot of fun
to be with
um it's very much the same spirit so
they are also very focused on saying
what works and what doesn't
uh there's two things I think that sort
of differentiate us uh I think the main
thing is that they tend to say the
future is just as important as as the
present uh this is one of the reasons
why they worry about existential risk
they worry about the fact that what
about you know us us sort of running uh
uh running out of track in a million
years or something I think that's
intellectually interesting but it's just
not how people react certainly not most
people in the poor part of the world but
even in the rich part of the world if
you really thought the future was just
as important as a present
all you would do was eat porridge every
day and save all the rest to your
descendants we don't right you the
honest answer is we actually spend most
of the money on ourselves on our
immediate surroundings then we spend
some money on our descendants we
typically spend it through investment in
infrastructure and in learning so that
we're basically saying here is a little
bit more of wealth here's a lot more of
information now go fend for yourself
that's pretty much how we actually do it
and that makes for a very different sort
of setup because the
Ultras or the effect of altruist
although the you know they'll say they
care a lot about people right now
they're sort of
the way they think end up focusing a lot
on the future likewise they also like to
focus on on animals for instance where
and again I think they make some
fascinating stories I I'm a vegetarian
because I don't want to kill animals I I
love the fact that they focus on animals
but again I tend to see it as a
professional Economist as a way of
saying it's about how much people value
these these animals not about the
animals in and of themselves uh and and
that's a very different sort of approach
uh so again you know I tend to probably
say it's a little more important to to
save humans I see the um similarities
with regards to what is the best way to
get a return on the money that we put in
that was what sort of aligned it for me
and I also that's something I hadn't
considered William mccaskill's been on
the show I found him very compelling I
think he's a really lovely dude big fan
of Toby odd big fan of Nick Bostrom and
everybody coming out of that world but
you are right
um
in a perfect hermetically sealed sandbox
you might be able to say well look we've
got you know
14.5 trillion future human lives that
will spread across the Galaxy if we make
these steps and get us there but you
need to account for human irrationality
you need to account for human biases
like hyperbolic discounting and you know
self-serving bias and stuff like that so
you need to go okay I understand that
that would be optimal but I need to
factor in the fact that all of the
people around us are going to spend most
of their money on themselves they're not
going to leave everything to Future
Generations they are going to inherently
be selfish even if they try to be
selfless so yeah I think and if I could
just I would actually tend to go uh one
step further because you're absolutely
right that's that's how people act but I
think that also tells us about what is
our actual preferences about this uh so
people will say well you know if you ask
them do you care about the future
nobody's going to be you know Annoying
and say no [__] them or whatever you're
just gonna say
um uh I I really want us to focus on the
future but then when you vote when you
spend your money you're very clearly
saying look I care somewhat for the
future but I actually care a lot for
right now and for the next year and that
kind of thing and I think we need to
reflect that and and the the second part
is also it makes a slightly more boring
stories uh because it's fun to talk
about you know us going out and
colonizing uh the universe and all that
stuff and it's slightly more boring
talking about how do we make better
education in developing countries for
sixth graders
but this is what's actually going to fix
a lot of the problems and of course also
what is going to get us to the Stars
quicker if you will because you know I I
think there's something slightly wrong
about us thinking about going to the
Stars while a lot of people are still
starving uh and and you know more
fundamentally you know if we actually
get the whole world together there's
also a much greater chance that people
are going to be saying we should also
fix global warming we should also fix
lots of other things because now we're
so rich that we can actually afford to
care about the future
so education is one of the longest
levers that you found what is another
one you got you managed to spend 10
billion and get 600 back not bad what is
another very long lever that you
discovered so there's so there's 12 all
in all another one is maternal and
newborn Health uh one of those things
that I didn't know anything about really
uh so every year
300 000 moms die in uh uh uh close to
childbirth from childbirth and about 2.3
million kids die each year in the first
28 days of their life here in on on the
planet
and most of these deaths are absolutely
avoidable so you know a lot of women uh
used to die in rich countries uh it was
actually such that uh you know upper uh
class women died more uh because they
went to hospitals you know in the 1800s
and of course the doctor fresh from
operating on somebody else came and
helped her uh delivery it's not a good
time bad idea bad idea uh so so uh but
but you know we fundamentally fixed this
in the rich world but you know every two
minutes a mom died nine nine kids die
and we could do something about this so
the simple and these are really you know
sort of almost strikingly simple things
is something the World Health
Organization called bee monk this is one
of the reasons why these these sorts of
solutions don't work right then that's
not fun uh but it's basic obstetric uh
and emergency uh
maternal and newborn Health Care see I
just screwed it up something along those
lines anyway so it's a you know it's a
simple list of things that we should do
so it's for instance make sure that you
have clean operating environment
yeah you sound like soap and
disinfectant yeah that's probably a good
idea but if you think about it you know
about a third of all these areas uh in
in the uh in low and Low Middle income
countries they don't have uh uh clean
water they don't have clean sanitation
they often lack of uh disinfectants
um about a third of all the kids that
die die from as fiction so they
basically don't get to breathe uh and I
again I didn't know this but if you if
you take even just you know European
kids are rich uh country kids about 80
that come out of mom they just start
breathing right away uh about 15 of them
need you know that shove in the and the
back end to get them going okay and then
they start gasping right but the last
five percent actually need a little mask
and then you pump air into their lungs
and then they start breathing and they
survive this little bag it cost what
sixty dollars or something and it can
save 25 kids over a period of two or
three years
why don't we have this and and there's
part of the solution is or part of the
reason is that this is not a high
priority thing you know if you talk to
politicians everywhere you know
politicians typically being old often
also men uh they'll want you know cancer
hospitals or stuff that they and their
wives and others die from uh and and and
maternal health is just far down the
line uh it's also you know this little
back that's not fun if you if you've
ever seen if you haven't you should uh
the machine that says ping do you
remember that one from uh the uh Monte
python it's a month's python sketch
where they're giving birth to uh they're
helping a woman give birth and but the
doctors and the administrators only
really focused on all the expensive
machines they have and especially this
one machine that says ping uh and that's
really you know there's there's
something Miss oh the woman yes yeah so
so it you know doctors love and I I
totally get that right they love you
know the exciting stuff and this mask
thing is is just not one of them so what
we're trying to say is you should invest
in these cheap simple things it turns
out that the total cost is about 4.9
billion dollars two billion of that is
women's time so that's actually not
money that we need to come up with but
it's of course still a cost because we
need to get women into facilities to
give birth instead of giving it back
home because then they have that
emergency option opportunities in the
hospitals
but so for about five billion dollars a
year we could make benefits that would
basically save 1.4 Million Lives let's
say 166 000 women each year at say 1.2
million kids
how amazing is that and the cost is so
uh or the benefit is so great that each
dollar will deliver 87 of social good so
you know those are the kinds of things
they're slightly boring they're not
things we you usually knew about but
they're just incredibly effective
they're not climate change but they're
something in some sense much much better
because they actually work right now
they'll help a huge chunk of of people
either getting better off as an
education or just simply surviving and
they'll make life much better at very
very low cost
let me do a little recap here to make
sure that I've got my brain in order so
the first person that I learned about
why climate change is such a powerful
existential risk from is Mike Solana
that writes pirate-wise the sub stack
and what he said was that
um he was talking about demographic
collapse and he was saying that there's
no smoke in the sky there's no plumes
there's no hurricane there's no forest
fires nothing galvanizes people to get
after it what it seems like that you're
saying here is there are lots of very
boring very unsexy very kind of behind
the scenes no press release
solutions that we can spend money on
which will do the thing that ostensibly
a lot of climate activism is trying to
do presumably the reason that people are
doing climate activism is because they
want to save human lives people
proselytize about the fact that they
want to save human lives specifically in
the most poverty-stricken regions you
don't care about poor people so on and
so forth but my time with Alex Epstein
taught me that a lot of the green
policies that are being enacted hurt
people from profit poverty significantly
more than they do developed countries so
when you're doing this
climate approach when people are
obsessed in climate as the highest the
longest lever point in order to affect
people from poverty they are applying a
salve to everything which actually needs
a slightly more targeted response they
are spending money in a way which
doesn't benefit and cause positive
changes in the now it is an investment
which takes a very long time to pay off
which may be better facilitated by
technology advances in the future there
are more targeted solutions that we can
do to people that are in these
poverty-stricken areas but because of
the cultural hold that climate alarmism
and activism and green New Deal in 169
different
target has taken hold of it's very
difficult to pull any one person out of
this because you have a a like a
cohesive group where if one person
decided to retract you'd say oh you
don't care about the climate you don't
care about poor people you go and
actually no I'm doing a thing that cares
more about poor people it's more
effective for poor people than what
you're doing but it doesn't seem that
way which means that they would then get
lambasted which is a disincentive for
them to go and then do it
and all of this together gets rolled
into how do we spend money to achieve
the goal and presumably the goal is
human well-being human flourishing an
acceptable standard of living for as
many people on planet Earth something
like that right whilst factoring in
I I would say the goal is a better world
and and that could be a lot of different
things it could be that you're better
off materially it could be that you
don't die and it could be that you have
a better environment and we try to you
know balance all those uh it turns out
that it's very much hard you know when
you ask people and it's not very
surprising uh they care a lot more about
not dying than they care about yeah uh
having uh having more wetlands and so
much of the effect of stuff that we have
is either getting people out of poverty
or uh getting them out of death
so in this regard I loved your summary
was I was I wrong with my children no no
no I think that's that's great and and
one more thing you know when people say
and this is absolutely true climate
change will affect the poorest the most
that's absolutely true but what you have
to remember is
poor people
so they're most affected by by
infectious diseases or bad environments
or uh you know any kind of hurricane
whether it's expensive and in unreliable
energy access absolutely and and so you
know the the main point is there's
something slightly odd about the whole
idea of us saying you know what
I see you you uh you talk to uh some
person in the really poor and you say I
really care about you I want to help you
I'm not going to drive to work tomorrow
and oh and sorry and that will actually
mean that I won't emit CO2 which will
mean in a hundred years your descendants
will be much warmer but slightly less
much warm that's just that just seems
almost careless uh you know about these
people the real point is that you why
wouldn't you want to help them now and
by making them better off of course you
will also make them more resilient to
climate and to all these other things
that they're challenged with so again
it's an efficiency conversation of
saying do you want to do a lot of good
or do you just want to feel good and you
know I I hope that a lot of people
actually want to do good but yes you're
absolutely right it's really really hard
to have this conversation and and I
think it's also important to just take a
little bit a step away from from climate
change it's not just climate change you
know it's also a lot of other things you
know people care about plastic straws in
the ocean and stuff I I you know I think
that's great but again you know let's
get a sense of proportion here there's
uh
one other solution there is
1.4 million people that die from
tuberculosis every year
last year tuberculosis was again the
world's leading infectious disease
killer you know covet disrupted that in
2020 and 2021 uh but yeah this has been
a huge Kelly it's killed a billion
people over the last 200 years uh every
fourth person that you
we didn't know but in the 1800s it died
died from tuberculosis and yet we fixed
in the rich world and then we sort of
think oh it's fixed everywhere no it's
not and again
because we fixed it we know very very
well how to fix this is about making
sure that there's enough medication that
people keep taking it you have to take
it for six months so it's actually
somewhat complicated most of us forget
to take our pills after two weeks when
we get better and then you need to
overcome some of the stigma and you need
to make sure that people actually get uh
uh found the the people who are sick we
uh there's about 11 million people who
are sick every year but we only uh I
identify about six million of them and
that's what keeps the infection going
because there's a lot of people who
don't get uh diagnosed and hence either
die or just pass on the uh tuberculosis
this again would cost in the order of
five billion dollars a year but the
benefits in terms of saving so over the
long run we'd save about a million
people uh and in the short run because
you actually need to ramp it up we'd
save about 600 000 people yeah that's
still pretty damn good and imagine we
could do that for every dollar spent
would do 46 dollars worth of good so you
know the point that we're trying to keep
saying is that there's these amazing
things that we really make a huge
difference and that would also make
people more concerned about all other
things you know when once you get out of
poverty you'll actually start caring
about climate change uh and and of
course as you point out also uh reliable
energy is incredibly important it's one
of the things that mean that we are not
affected by you know incredible heat
waves or incredible cold waves because
we can cool and heat our homes and and
not surprisingly most people for
instance in sub-Saharan Africa want that
as well not primarily because of global
warming but simply because it's really
uncomfortable if it's very very warm or
very very cold and it's always been that
way now we've made it a little more
uncomfortably warm and a little less
uncomfortably cold in Africa overall
it's still a big problem and they would
want most of the uh the heating and
cooling any anyway the point here is if
you get well off or if you at least get
out of poverty you're much more likely
to actually have a good life and you
know be able to afford the stuff that'll
make it possible for you and your kids
to start learning and and and doing
better
I saw a tweet from you that said cold
kills much more than heat each year heat
kills half a million people but cold
kills 4.5 million people
how does that work how's the nine times
more deaths from cold than there is from
Heat so this is very well established
this is from a the world's first
estimate of a truly Global estimate we
have very bad data from many places in
the world we have lots of great data for
for rich countries but we only have
mediocre data for a lot of of a poor
place in the world uh this was from the
Lancet magazine uh and so what we know
is that if you look across temperatures
if it's very cold people die more if
it's very warm people die more and so
what they're basically looking at is
they say where do you die the least and
it turns out that there's an optimal
temperature almost everywhere on the
planet it shifts so so in England it's
what eight degrees and in India is
perhaps why I don't know uh 20 something
degrees centigrade and now I'm totally
lost in Fahrenheit but cold in England
and warming in India and the point is
most of the time we spend time below the
optimal temperature that is colder than
the optimal temperature that's why most
people actually die from cool especially
in the cold week months of the year
people especially old people will uh
stay inside if they're if they're not
really wealthy and typically all people
suffer more in this way they can't
afford to keep their home quite as
heated as they'd like and so what
happens is when it's cold your body
constricts uh the the uh the uh
uh the blood vessels to keep your inner
core uh heated but that drives up your
blood pressure so we know everyone has
higher blood pressure and winter time
and that means you have much higher
chance of getting a stroke or a blood
clot or many other complications that
sometimes lead to a death and because
this happens for literally almost
everyone on the planet this is makes for
a lot of deaths uh you know it's not as
it's like smoking deaths it's not
something that you you take a smile and
then you die but it's something of a
statistical correlation this is what all
the people who've looked at heat and
cold essay when it gets really hot you
die or you have a higher risk of dying
and when it gets cold you have a higher
risk of of dying unfortunately most of
humanity is spent way more time being a
little too cold so the amazing thing is
if you look at India because they've
done studies for India as well uh India
you know you'd imagine a lot of people
die from heat but actually again about
seven times more people die from coal
and this is because it's very easy to
die and very easy to see when you die
from heat because you die right after
you die you know within the next 24
hours that's why heat waves are great TV
but cold waves you don't die the next
day you die over the next 30 days
because you've constricted your blood uh
vessels you've increased your risk of a
heart attack and then maybe 15 days down
the line you get this heart attack at
but yeah it doesn't show up on CNN the
problem here is again that we're we're
Guided by what we see on TV rather than
what the evidence actually tell us now
this doesn't mean global warming is not
a problem because global warming will
mean will have more heat waves and we'll
have fewer cold waves in the short term
it actually turns out that that's good
for mankind overall because we'll see
more heat waves that'll mean more dead
but we'll see fewer cold waves and
because many more people die from coal
that'll actually be a net a benefit for
mankind uh over the long run of course
eventually we'll run out of coal deaths
and so it may turn out to be a problem
the other part is it's much much easier
to avoid uh heat death than it is cold
death because heat deaths you really
just need access to air conditioning for
like you know 48 hours or so uh we know
you can open up the malls that kind of
thing there's a lot of ways that you can
make sure people get more cooling free
avoiding cold deaths you need heating on
for months on end especially for poor
people and that's one of the reasons why
uh uh not having access to enough energy
is actually really really harmful uh
there's a wonderful study in the U.S
that looked at what happened when you
had fracking the fracking Revolution uh
fracking Revolution meant that gas
prices dropped to about half as much
that matters because the vast amount of
people in the US use gas for heating uh
and so they estimated what that mean the
gas became cheaper well especially poor
people kept their homes better heated
and that of course means they die less
the net effect this uh study estimate is
that every year 11 000 people didn't die
in the U.S from coal death you saved 11
000 deaths from cheaper gas and so
there's something weird about the way
that we worry about oh my goodness you
know the the uh uh the Heap Dome and 800
people died that's absolutely something
we should be concerned about but we
should have sort of a sense of
proportion that you know uh fracking
probably saved 11 000 people every year
every year about uh you know so so about
20 000 people die from heat in the U.S
but 170 000 people die from coal why are
we only talking about the heat deaths
and not the cold deaths
you've run a couple of numbers
previously to do with education to do
with tuberculosis et cetera Etc what is
the return on money when it gets spent
on climate and green movement stuff
so it depends on how you spend it uh if
you so the best analyzed uh data is for
the EU they had a 2020 climate policy uh
and that has been sort of looked back at
and we've analyzed in a lot of different
ways and this simple answer and this is
wrong in the sense that there there's so
much uncertainty that it's on an order
of magnitude estimate is that every
dollar spent
avoid it about three sets of climate
damage
it could actually have been 30 cents
back on the dollar if we've been really
really lucky it could also happen even
less uh but it was not a good deal right
instead of spending a dollar and doing
three cents of good mostly in poor
countries in a long time from now
the dollar and done you know 97 cents uh
more good most climate policies are very
close to one or below one so they do
very poorly uh uh and and and that's
basically because politicians love to
put a lot of restrictions on yeah no no
no you can't solve climate change with
nuclear power for instance which would
be somewhat cheaper or switch from cold
to gas which would often be a net net
positive for people that's something
that people would actually want to do as
the US did in the 2010s uh instead they
say no no you have to put up solar
panels or wind turbines which are often
fairly expensive so uh the estimate is
that most climate policies is somewhere
between 10 cents back on the dollar and
maybe even a dollar maybe a dollar and a
half so you can do pretty good policy
but typically you don't there is one
policy that's incredibly good so we
actually did
a whole project just for climate uh
together with 50 of the world's top
climate economists and three Noble
alerts to look at where can you spend a
dollar and do the most good just for
climate so I'm not talking about well
you could do something about
tuberculosis or something else just the
climate it turned out that the best
long-term policy was investment in green
energy r d
and this is not very surprising really
because imagine if you could come up
with innovations that would make green
energy cheaper than fossil fuels not the
cheaper that we're saying right now that
you know still needs hundreds of
billions of dollars in subsidies from
you know uh the inflation production act
or something and and the reason why
China and India and everywhere else is
only you know taking up a little bit of
this but actually cheaper which of
course would mean that people would just
jump on it you wouldn't need any big
Summits people would just do it
themselves because it was cheaper if we
had those kinds of breakthroughs uh this
could be fourth generation nuclear again
there's a lot of reasons why fourth
generation might actually fail us at the
end but imagine if fourth generation was
just
vastly cheaper than anything else China
India Africa everybody would just buy it
and you know tons of it and the world
would decarbonize it wouldn't be the
complete solution because there's lots
of other ways that we need to
decarbonize apart from electricity but
it would be a big part of it so the
point is this is the solution that we've
always used if you think back there's
there's a good story back in the 18 uh
50s uh the world was basically running
out of whales
we were hunting whales almost to
extinction because whales happen to have
this wonderful whale blubber that burns
really really brightly so you know most
rich people in Western Europe and North
America
would keep their homes lit with this
wonderful new whale blubber it was much
cleaner much nicer much brighter right
the solution to saving the whales wasn't
to tell tell everyone I'm sorry could
you go back to the dirty old stuff that
doesn't burn as well
yeah you couldn't convince people to do
that what you did convince them with was
that we found oil and so you know we
found oil first in Pennsylvania and then
everybody else everywhere else and you
could basically make the same clean
burning oil product
but without having to go out in the
middle of the ocean and kill whales and
just get a little bit of blower which
was incredibly more inefficient so
fundamentally Innovation saved the
whales instead of telling people no you
have to do without we came up with an
innovation that was better we've done
that in many other ways you know back in
the 1970s when everybody worried about
uh there would not be enough food to be
for people the solution was not to tell
him I'm sorry could everyone just eat a
little less and then we'll send it down
to the poor people the solution was the
Green Revolution the you know uh the guy
who actually got the Nobel Prize for
this in in 1970 Norman Bullock he was
the leader of finding ways to make seeds
more effective uh and so he basically
made these new yield higher yield seeds
they would you know delivered two or
three times as much rice or wheat or
corn per acre or per hectare and so you
could basically give this to poor people
and they could make more more food
themselves this is what saved for
instance India and many other countries
this is why India has gone from you know
basically a basket case in the 70s to
now being the world's leading rice
exporter
because we innovated them so it's not
again about saying oh you know be a
little more hungry then we'll save the
world you know it's about technology and
that's how we're going to save global
warming that's going to how we're going
to fix global warming by Innovation if
we can come up with technologies that
are cheaper and less carbon intensive
we've already done one you know uh
fracking which basically made us very
cheap gas which has meant that the U.S
has switched over from coal to gas gas
emits about half as much that's a great
climate solution is not the final
climate solution because gas is still
emitting CO2 and so we need to go
further but you know surely that's one
of the first things we should do to get
sure that Europe that Africa that India
and that China starts fracking so that
they can also switch away from coal and
start using gas instead and become much
cleaner and emit much less so again the
point here is simply to say there are
smarter ways to do this and they're dumb
ways and unfortunately we seem to to be
insistent and saying no we're going to
do the dumb stuff which will be
incredibly costly and actually not work
it's strange to think that the the
biggest point of contribution that you
can make as opposed to trying to wag
your finger or get a Swedish girl to wag
her finger and say you should change
this is something that you should do is
just offer up a solution that people are
naturally going to want to do because
the incentives end up being aligned what
you're trying to do is force people
through shame or guilt or or sad imagery
to do something that they fundamentally
don't want to do and you know incentives
will as incentives do basically like
people are going to end up aligning
themselves with what it is that they
want uh you were talking there about the
whales I also saw a tweet from you that
said the polar bear population is
increasing polar bears were intensely
hunted but in 1976 the world banned much
hunting the polar bear population
recovered and now is at its highest in
six decades
yeah and and you know again this is just
simply a question of saying this is not
saying that overall climate change might
actually be a problem in the long run
for polar bears I I think the science is
much less clear than what they want to
tell us uh but there is undoubtedly a
problem but that we are so focused on
making climate change the only problem
and so we're somehow thinking no no no I
want to help save polar bears so I'm
gonna you know not drive my car tomorrow
which is just like the weirdest kind of
connection that you know in a hundred
years maybe I'll uh I I and everybody
else in the U.S will save a quarter of a
polar bear what whereas you know if you
actually cared about polar bears we
should stop shooting them yeah the the
amazing thing is that every year so
there's about you know 26 000 polar
bears in the world right now
um uh and every year we shoot 700 polar
bears
if you're worried about polar bears stop
shooting polar bears is you know it's
not rocket science and so again I simply
try to point out what works and what
doesn't I actually forgot to say just on
the research and development for green
energy we also did a cost benefit
analysis and that and of course it's
very very uncertain because who you know
you're basically making arguments about
what's going to happen the far future
but what we estimated was with world's
best Minds was that every dollar spent
will do eleven dollars of social goods
so essentially by investing one dollar
on green energy r d you will help push
forward the date when green energy will
be so cheap that everybody will switch
over which will then reduce climate
damages in the long run about eleven
dollars that's a great investment it's
not as great as some of these other
things I'm arguing for but it's still a
great one it's by far the best one we
can do in climate also there are again
as we said before you need to account
for the fact that we have this desire to
be seen as altruistic and empathetic and
so on and so forth you need to account
for the biases that everybody's got at
the moment and one of them is we should
be focusing on climate so perhaps
it's still within the realm of climate
but it's the highest leverage point of
doing that
um might be a nice halfway house to get
people to think a little bit more
um nuanced about this kind of a problem
yeah yeah and and look I I I really
appreciate those thoughts uh we've tried
for a very long time to get people to
think about stuff that's you know
fundamentally boring but incredibly good
uh and we've tried all of these
different things so what we're trying
right now is simply to say we made all
these promises we're going to fail on
pretty much all the promises if we can't
do it all shouldn't we do the smarter
stuff first so we're simply saying 12
amazing things uh just to give you a
sense of proportion uh if you add up all
of these
it'll cost about 35 billion dollars
there's another 6 billion in Social
costs that you know the mom's waiting
that kind of thing uh but we need 35
billion dollars
35 billion dollars is basically couch
money right yeah for the world this is
almost nothing you know we spend what
three times as much on Cosmetics
globally every year so yes we could
probably afford 35 billion dollars a
year the benefit
would be that we would avoid
4.2 million deaths each and every year
we'd save 4.2 Million Lives and we'd
make the poor poor half of the world 1.1
trillion dollars better off every year
that's almost one dollar per person per
day in the poor half of the world are
you not just screaming at the walls in
your office every day with these figures
in your hands and with you know these
campaigns that everybody else is putting
out you must just be losing your you
must want to throw yourself off the roof
like why why why I clearly haven't yeah
yeah well there's no praise to your
sanity for for sticking up with it I I
think yes we we have a saying at the uh
in my Think Tank the Copenhagen
consensus that you know we would love
for everyone to be incredibly rational
uh but you know we'd love to for
everyone to do the right thing but
actually we'll settle for just people
doing it slightly less wrong
uh and and you know there's a lot of
reasons why we don't get it right and
you know a lot of it is just simply
we're egotistical creatures right I mean
fundamentally most of so David Hume back
from the 1700s uh you know who described
how we he would sit in the reading the
paper and read about a big earthquake in
China that killed you know hundreds of
thousands of people and then he'd cut
his thumb on the on the paper and he you
know he'd be a lot more focused and he's
no different from the rest of us of
course that's how we you know we act we
just care a lot more about you know I
just cut my thumb but it doesn't mean
we're uncaring people it just means
we're you know sort of limited
caring people and so I just want to get
our attention to at least saying all
right look you're going to spend most of
the money on yourself and you're going
to spend some on really silly stuff and
that's fine that's how the world is but
when we're not when we're actually
saying I want to do this because I want
to do good in the world and that's as
you pointed out sometimes when people
talk about climate change and many other
things when they talk about plastic
straws and everything else when we
really want to do good in the world then
let's really do good in the world and
not just uh end up feeling good about
ourselves and if I can push people a
little bit to the smarter Solutions uh
you know I would love us to do all 35
billion dollars but I'll settle for you
know Elon Musk saying I'm gonna do that
one thing or whatever it takes uh so you
know we're we're throwing out these 12
amazing things and hoping some of it
will stick
how dumb of a policy is net zero
possible palsy well look in the long run
we'll probably get to Net Zero I I
struggle to believe that we won't be Net
Zero in a couple of centuries uh but
um but for 2050 or you know some of
these states that are talking about it
even before it's just absolutely Bonkers
uh for two reasons one of them is we
don't have the technology for at least
half of it and even if we had it would
be fantastically expensive which of
course is why you know most people talk
about it but most people don't actually
want to do it there was a wonderful
story in Politico just today uh about
Germany where they say uh uh that most
Germans would love to do all their
climate uh goals but they are somewhat
skeptical about paying for all of that
and you know that's that's sort of the
basic dilemma of most of these things
that you talk about this stuff but then
if you actually realize how much it's
going to cost you can see that there's
going to be nobody saying yes to this
there's one study of how much it would
cost uh it was from nature uh uh how
much it would cost for the average
American to reduce his or her or the the
US carbon emissions by 80 and the cost
would be so you know pretty far from Net
Zero by 2050 would be more than five
thousand dollars per person per year so
you know if you're a family of four
that's 20 thousand dollars for you every
year and if you want to go all the way
or they couldn't actually get the model
to do it all the way it would cost more
than twice as much so fundamentally this
is just not going to happen in any
realistic sense uh uh McKinsey did a
study for what it's going to cost to go
nuts early estimated like many others
have done if we do really smartly which
we won't do but even if we did it would
cost you know in the order of five to
six trillion dollars a year it would
cost India about nine percent of its GDP
every year remember the total budget
intake in India is about 12 so they'd
have to spend almost their entire budget
on netzera of course I'm not going to do
that yeah so we we just got to get to
grips with the fact that we're talking
about these policies that are absolutely
fanciful and even if we did just
remember if everyone in the rich World
Went Net Zero
today
and stayed that way for the rest of the
century it would reduce temperatures by
about half a degree Centigrade or one
degree Fahrenheit uh so yes it would be
noticeable but it wouldn't have fixed
most of the problem that's of course
because the vast majority of emissions
are going to come from China India and
Africa
who are all places that want to get much
richer so again we have no sense in
proportion here uh Nets here is both
impossible and it's probably also a net
syrup by 2050 or something is an
incredibly ineffective way to help the
world it's a good idea to say we want to
fix climate but I think there's
something wrong in saying we want to fix
climate to the extent that we're just
going to leave off a lot of the money
that could have helped save a lot of
other stuff and it's also wrong to tell
people we're going to go down a road
that will eventually make every one of
you yellow vest protesters because it's
just going to be so expensive
so there's a limited amount of time
resources money energy Focus that can be
spent on looking after the world
there are trade-offs between going green
stopping poverty Health pollution
women's education child mortality etc
etc
at the moment the most widespread
of these whether it go to public
campaigns political campaigns government
talks Davos conferences the ability to
click that button to offset your carbon
when you fly on a plane the ability to
round up and donate money to Greenpeace
or whoever it might be all of these
different vectors could be finding
pointing at places that were longer
levers ones that would give you a better
multiplier on all of these given that we
have
what seems to be
um
a culture of altruism right that's like
one positive white pilled way of looking
at what's happening you know people want
to make an impact the problem is that
the less sexy risks and the ones that
Galvanize them more poorly
what is a way that you foresee of trying
to get people to buy into your 12 points
so I think there's one thing and and
we've talked about that in several
different ways you need to get people
off the ledge if climate change is the
end of the world of course that's the
only thing you should worry about you
know AOC said it very beautifully when
when she was talking about there's only
12 years left it's you know it's been a
sort of recurrent phrase at least since
1972 when the UN first told us we just
had 10 years left uh but you know the
the we only have 12 years left she said
and you're worried about how we're going
to pay for it that makes perfect sense
if the world was really ending this is
the only thing you should be focused on
so it makes sense if you believe you're
at the on the uh on the uh on the edge
and so we need to First pull people back
and that's what I've been trying to do
you know you you mentioned the uh the
polar bears the uh the fact that you
know a lot more people die from cold and
heat uh I have another graph that I love
uh which is basically how many people
die from climate related disasters uh so
we have pretty good data at least the
last 100 years uh and in the 1920s on
average every year people die from
climate related disasters or cult uh uh
cold and heat and drought storms floods
and and extreme temperatures uh about
half a million people died each year uh
100 years ago now most people would
certainly when you look at the
presentation think that that had
increased its own it's actually
dramatically decreased such that in the
last decade in the 2010s It Was Eighteen
thousand last year it was 11
000 people globally and mind you we've
quadrupled in size so actually the
individual risk has gone down even more
we have seen a decline of about 98 in in
in total deaths from climate related
disasters this has nothing to do with
climate this is everything to do with
the fact that when you're richer you're
more technologically advanced you don't
die as much you're more resilient we've
just simply become much better at
dealing with whatever nature throws at
you which is one of the reasons why we
should make sure that the rest of the
world also gets out of poverty so they
can get the same benefits that we're
having but the reality here is Once you
pull people back from that ledge you can
then start talking about now all right
so what do you want to do do you want to
you know not drive your car tomorrow and
help a hapless guy in a hundred years
and then tiny tiny amount or do you want
to do something really really effective
right now and once you point that out
once you've taken away the end of the
work I think it's a lot easier to get
people to start realizing oh wait
there's some really really good stuff
here but what I'm trying to do with this
particular thing and that's because I've
you know this is what I've been saying
for 20 years and failed
um so what I'm trying right now is is
basically to say look whatever else it
is you're doing I'm simply saying why
don't we spend 35 billion dollars couch
change you know spend on all the other
stuff that you want but let's just spend
this tiny tiny tiny amount and make the
world immensely much better how about
that and I think even a lot of people
you know even the aocs of the world
would also say sure I'd love to do that
and then go let me go back and worry
about climate change and that's fine
that's sort of another way to you know I
would probably still disagree with her
but you know fundamentally I want to get
everybody on board with this boat we've
made all these promises we're not
actually going to deliver why don't we
at least do the really smart stuff
that's incredibly cheap first
where should people go if they want to
support these efforts and and try and
make some sort of an impact themselves
so there's a number of different
we're not looking for money to do this
we're not the right guys to go out and
actually fix uh tuberculosis then it's a
stock TB or it's uh uh a Red Cross or
many many of these other organizations
it's also very much about getting your
politicians to think about this it's
also just about getting that
conversation going so you know I'm
really hoping that when people watch
this uh they'll they'll simply start
having these conversations with their uh
with their kids or their peers or you
know their grandparents around the
tables and say why aren't we focused on
these things uh I'm coming out with a
book next month uh it's also available
on our website uh but it's yeah I'm
still working on it uh we're publishing
this in 35 papers around the world so
you can go to our website it's called
Copenhagen consensus.com
halftime uh and that's basically because
we're at halftime but nowhere near
halfway right so we're basically saying
let's do the SMART stuff now uh you can
also follow me on Twitter uh and and
obviously I'm hoping to help give that
sort of input that will make you better
at pushing all the other people to
become slightly more aware that this is
how we should be spending our money
because at the end of the day this is
not going to happen unless also you know
everybody yeah I I want it's not you
know I live in the same country as
greater tunberg I think she's you know I
think she's a great girl I I really have
a lot of respect for her because you
know she's heard the message loud and
clear the world is ending and it seems
like nobody's doing enough so I
understand why she's doing what she's
doing but I would love her to then say
why aren't we doing the real stuff first
right so if we could take away some of
the fear I think a lot of people like
Greta tunberg could actually start
saying I want to do the real stuff and
then of course we could actually get our
politicians to do a little you know a
little less of the dumb stuff and a
little more of the smart stuff
Beyond I really appreciate you I like
the fact that you are very measured with
the way that you put this stuff across I
think that you need to be delicate when
sort of broaching this topic with people
because you'll just trigger a response
that's going to get them to dig their
heels in and ignore what you're saying I
think it's definitely the right demeanor
and the right sort of rhetoric to go
about this stuff with uh very much
looking forward to the book coming out
and yeah I really hope that this has
opened a lot of people's eyes every time
that I speak to someone that's got a
measured response when it comes to how
we should be dealing with current
problems facing the world uh it does
give me a glimmer of hope so uh
congratulations for for doing that dude
I really appreciate you thank you for
your time today thank you Chris what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]